it's not just russia's overt military
buildup around ukraine that's got
western allies worried
they suspect covert action as well
the uk accusing russia of plotting to
install a pro-kremlin leader to head the
government here in kiev
the foreign office claimed this former
ukrainian mp yevan marayev is being
considered as a potential candidate
his facebook page seemingly making light
of the allegation
in a rare release of classified
information the uk also alleged other
former ukrainian politicians are in
contact with russian spies involved in
planning for an attack on ukraine
the foreign secretary liz trust said the
information being released today shines
a light on the extent of russian
activity designed to subvert ukraine and
is an insight into kremlin thinking
russia must de-escalate end its
campaigns of aggression and
disinformation and pursue a path of
diplomacy
as the uk and our partners have said
repeatedly any russian military
incursion into ukraine would be a
massive strategic mistake with severe
costs
britain's spy agencies are better known
for keeping secrets than making a splash
but at a time when information is being
used as a tool by either side to attack
the other it's perhaps not surprising
the uk has effectively gone on the
offensive
i think it's uh it's a very unusual
thing for the foreign officers to do and
no doubt it's based on uh intelligence
gathering
at the highest level
um
but i think it's a useful uh
thing to do because what it demonstrates
to russia very clearly
is that we know their intent we are in
no doubt at all as to what they're
trying to achieve and that
we will expose them at every turn
and i think that's a very useful lesson
for russia to know
the kremlin denied the british
allegations accusing the uk of peddling
fake news
but this crisis is real and the stakes
are high
so high that the head of germany's navy
pictured here in delhi chose to resign
this weekend over comments he made about
president putin and crimea that
contradicted his nato allies it is easy
to even give him the respect he he
really demands and probably also
deserves
russia is an old country russia is an
important country the crimea peninsula
is
gone they've never come back this is it
this is a fact
on the ground new shipments of u.s
weapons to bolster ukraine's defenses
are evidence that weeks of diplomacy
have done little to diffuse tensions
neither side letting up on the pressure
debra haynes sky news